[Music]
should england's best defender have a
different gender yeah will the next spy
you love be a man woman or none of the
above
now that daniel craig's officially
concluded his 48-year run is james bond
speculation over who will replace him is
in full swing he could be tall or tan
british or brutish whatever he is he
must be gorgeous which eliminates kill
me the homely disgusting wretch
but it's a sign of the times that the
biggest casting question this week is uh
should the next double 07 be non-binary
and in the time it took to read that
sentence china already tested another
hypersonic missile of course non-binary
refers to someone who identifies as
neither male nor female and non-amanda
binary is anyone who is in amanda bynes
according to bond producer barbara
broccoli
she's not totally ruling it out the
non-bind saying in a recent interview
quote who knows i mean i think it's open
we just have to find the right actor she
also said the next bond will still
likely be a man and should be british
imagine if it were a woman in those car
chases am i right they'll have to keep
stopping to pee
a sexist would say
terrible that you laughed at that so
maybe the wokification will happen
slowly maybe he won't use a gun in the
next film if so it might look like this
where are you
where's the bomb
you can't get away with this oh but
james i already have by the time you
track me down it will be too late
oh james you're so predictable
all i have to do is push this button and
the building will be level there's only
one thing that can stop a madman like
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wait
that was good
don't see that on fox and friends hey uh
jamie uh what do you make of this
non-binary option i gotta really rethink
this because i thought it non-binary
meant you were bad at math yes and um
now that i know no i think it's i don't
know i i don't know i'm not an expert on
in this area right but i feel like if uh
james bond is non-binary i feel like the
audience might be non-existent
um
isn't it going to be i feel like it's
going to be confusing whoever plays this
new james bond even with just that
person talking it's going to be a real
he said she said situation
um
yep
won't it be where the easy come in like
a bond
james bond or
jane bond for sure just definitely bond
and then we'll figure out the other part
i don't know it's it's it's a little
it's a little bit of a weird thing but
we'll see what happens look at daniel
craig by the way yeah you ever seen my
impression of him no can you see it yeah
that's i i can't stand him as bump
that's very good
dude
i just got nervous because i thought
daniel craig was here yes yes
all he does is like he has to purse his
lips
for two and a half hours like my sister
on instagram yeah
he is like he's like a a a thirsty chick
on instagram yeah that's it
and dude he's getting so old his
pronouns are gonna be are gonna be the
and bao pretty soon
remember the controversy was could a
james bond be blonde right that was
controversial what has happened to
society you know this is something that
i'm gonna bring up even though it's
tangential the real story is james bond
could be anything but short
oh we discriminate like we never talk
about the other discriminations that go
on
short people get discriminated in all
occupations except of course as talk
show hosts
but
you got to be good-looking it doesn't
matter what gender you got to be hot and
you got to be tall a couple of things i
think you're wrong okay uh the other
thing is i'm sure you're wrong
uh and
uh
sylvester case in point sylvester
stallone yeah he's america's hero he
wins every fight what are you living in
where does that look
we did we just fly back to 1978 excuse
me have you heard the word expendables
yes
four in a row some of which people
watched
he rocky six yes and a creed creed still
relevant still short you left out cobra
cobra and stop where my mom will shoot
right then he wanted me to leave out
stop with your mom's shoes
david save me
uh
i i think we're missing a really uh good
side of this story which goes back to
our last segment yes
bringing the country together come out
with a non-binary james bond and see how
quickly this country
unites you have the absurdity of this
idea no you know what though it could
break caitlyn jenner no
caitlyn jenner
tim the new bond
right caitlyn jenner is not non-binary
well
not double negative that's true thanks
for playing good but caitlyn jenner is
from the same era as sylvester stallone
thank you this is still thank you
yeah very good point almost was governor
joe bruce generous from that era i'm
sorry caitlyn jenner is later i can be
forgiven for that mistake yes you know
um uh just by default you're young here
um is bond just a relic of another era i
was gonna say i would never watch a
james bond movie with a non-binary james
bond but i've also never watched any
james bond movie
so yes it is yeah i'm way too young for
this segment yes you are is the voice in
your head why am i doing this segment no
no i love this segment yeah the new
movie's called james bond double 07
different pronouns
all right i'm going to shut up now hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else